It is time for Drew's News.
You're daily jump into the pile of good news leaves
and with me at the desk,
well, he's a crisp-ful day in man form.
(Ross laughs)
Ross Mathews
Hi everybody.
(crowd cheers)
Hi, in man form.
(crowd clapping)
Well today, we say goodbye to beauty week
Aw
(celestial music)
Aw!
Aw, we love beauty week!
It's okay, honestly,
every day for me,
it's always beauty week
Yeah.
On this show and in my mind,
because it's so important
and it needs to be deep and meaningful
and coming from the right place with the right messaging
and on Monday we had a huge promise,
100 beauty tips all week long, Ross did we do it?
We're almost there Drew,
we at 81 beauty tips,
(crowd cheers)
(crowd clapping)
we have, do the math, we have 19 more to go.
Okay?
Okay, all right,
are we gonna do it?
We're absolutely gonna hit
a hundred beauty tips for sure.
All right,
I can do tip number 82 right now.
Get it.
I would like to suggest investing
in a slip pillowcase mask,
they retail for usually somewhere under $30
and it's such an amazing investment.
Now, silk doesn't pick up as much pore clogging bacteria
as cotton does.
This is true.
We also did a story about how often
you're supposed to wash your pillow case,
it's way more than all of us do.
Yeah
(crowd laughing)
But it's hypoallergenic and it's resistant to dust mites,
urgh!
Ew!
So that's helpful and disgusting.
Okay, well I have tip number 83 if that's okay?
Give it to me now!
Okay,
anyone ever have a blemish?
Yes!
Oh god yeah.
Here's a little tip to get rid of it,
put a little salt and warm water on a cotton pad
and then press it against the zit
and it will help dry it out
and reduce swelling and redness,
if you don't have all those fancy creams,
a little salt water on a cotton swab, yeah.
I'll try it.
Okay.
You're welcome.
(crowd clapping)
Love a big reveal and speaking of reveals,
I've got one for you,
Ms. Barrymore right now.
Did you know that your book Rebel Homemaker
is now a New York times best seller!
You are a best selling cook book author!
Just announced.
Best seller!
I just found out!
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
We just found out,
Pilar we did it,
Pilar!
Aww!
It's so exciting and I'm just relieved
for the people who invested in us,
they deserve their money back.
(hand slams)
Yeah!
Say well done!
All right.
Plus it's a great book.
(upbeat music)